hello and welcome to Backstage and look
if you're wondering what you're watching
we're going to be doing something a
little different for the next 10 minutes
or so this is where we record our weekly
podcast and I'm joined Now by
entertainment reporter Claire Gregory
hello and TV and film reviewer Stevie
Wonder hello look well this is the first
time we've done a TV version of our
podcast and this is the point Claire
where you would say oh if you like what
you hear do rate and review make sure
you subscribe but as this is the TV
version we say uh if you would like to
hear more of what we talk about on the
full podcast just scan the QR code which
is coming up on your screen now you're
the American dream
Rags to Riches coming up on this week's
backstage it's the show where they
ripped up the scripts and spent Millions
on reshoots we're going to be talking
about Sky Atlantics the idol
[Music]
it's only just finished but we'll be
talking about the spin-off potential for
characters from Ted lasso
we all write our own stories and we talk
to Eva Longoria about her directorial
feature debut flaming hot
very quickly look if we're talking about
TV this week it is inescapable
unavoidable if you like the the we have
to bring up this morning the Phillips
Scofield Scandal are you okay are you
okay Claire Stevie are you okay we just
do this whole show
give it some some uh frame of reference
here Claire everyone is asking if
everyone is okay because because Holly
Willoughby returned to this morning
um with
plenty of viewers loads of people tuned
in to see what Holly was going to say
she'd had two weeks off while the
Philips Scandal Phillips Schofield
Scandal was uh happening she returned to
this morning and started with a
statement deep breath okay
um and earnestly asked the audience if
they were okay and went on to talk about
how she was troubled and shaken by
everything that's happened
um in recent weeks and then kind of just
launched off into the show proper at
which point um
rocks and what have you yeah Stevie this
must be utterly baffling for you though
as someone who's not from the UK and
just visiting this week and let's face
it didn't know who Phillips guys I have
no idea who Phillip Schofield was I came
in and it was just amazing because the
amount of coverage and everybody was
talking about it and like information
was leaking out so I got caught up in a
bit of the uh drama if you will and then
when I found out the case I was like oh
well interesting if you take them the
man out of the situation now the reason
that we are talking about it is is
because of this discussion I think now
to do with what the working environment
was like on this morning whether or not
it was a toxic atmosphere and really I
think the reason MPS are getting
involved now is is the whistleblowing
element of this and whether or not
people have felt comfortable on that
show for for years to come forward and
make any complaints that they might have
wanted to they talked about it in a
Committee hearing this week uh also
using the now famous yeah I mean that's
become a meme in itself it is the new
DOT
we've spoken about this so much now
really on the news but should we um move
on and talk about some reviews then I
mean sticking with something that's
quite controversial actually it hasn't
done been smooth sailing for the new Sky
Atlantic show the idol should we take a
quick look
I'm telling you right now these people
in here are gauging whether or not you
still got it
[Music]
all the noise
I'm sorry who are you
I'll see
[Music]
look
deep breath where do we even start this
one because actually the original script
ended up being completely ripped up
didn't it Stevie they'd spent Millions
on reshoots for this they had actually
shot four episodes already the the
showrunner Amy Simon's like turned it in
and they were all like we don't like
this fired her and then they had to
reshoot the whole thing so now the show
is five episodes which is a weird number
but I think budget wise that probably
was all they could afford in the end and
so when you watch this I'm I'm always
curious like which part what part is the
original and what's the new stuff and so
that was kind of my game but the show
itself Oh I thought it I thought it can
they showed me their first episodes I
won't tell you what happens in episode
two because you know episode one just
came out but the the kind of walk out
kind of energy was you know and and it's
just an icky show and uh I don't know do
you want to watch more we should say
this is the one created by Euphoria
showrunner Sam levison and the weekend
because it's the Euphoria showroom yeah
I think wow there's getting to be
something really edgy this is going to
be something good it's a terribly male
gay that they've gone there it's about
this uh pop star they compare her to
Brittany in the first episode she's uh
kind of returning after having something
of a breakdown and releasing new music
and all her team around her and they're
all sort of I mean not not just any old
actress
Lily Rose yeah who gives a decent
performance amongst what is kind of a
bit of a problematic show in other ways
I think my I I've just found it so
utterly unpalatable it's the the fact
that it's uh we're meant to be talking
about this being an exploitative
industry that Lily Rose Depp's character
is um is working it's done in such an
explosion
it's a horror show I mean if you if you
if you kind of think about it it's
almost like in inviting oh I'm giving
spoilers now but in the second episode
there's something there's references to
this being a horror movie and so that
that kind of adds on to the experience
again is this a show you want to keep on
watching because if this doesn't turn
you know if you don't want to see it
after the first episode why would you
kind of invested four more hours into
this it'll be interesting to see how
those audience figures do it hasn't
started brilliantly in the States but
you know plenty more to come so yeah
we'll see should we move on quickly to
talk about a new film that's coming out
this week which is really interesting
because it's even Longoria making her
film directorial debut and it's about
crisps it's called flaming hot I'm the
guy who helped bring the world the most
popular snack it's ever seen are you
ready
I will I've been ready look making a
movie based around a very specific genre
that's not that is not available in the
UK come on are we even gonna watch it
for that reason I mean it's so good I
mean like I as an American you can talk
about playing hot Cheeto with some
experience exactly not just America it's
southern Asia so outside of certain
territories UK um this thing is a very
very popular activity to make a film yes
about this a film we it we talked about
this earlier in our pod but basically uh
I agree with you this is kind of
stretching a theme kind of like really
why but in the world of films geared
towards the latinx community there
aren't that many stories that we that
they get to tell or get to see and the
fact that it's also inspirational like
it's you know this character uh Montana
is literally like comes from nothing and
then became a very high-powered person
over at PepsiCo this storyline is very
interesting
um and and I just love the fact that you
know the two leads Jesse Garcia and
Annie Gonzalez these are actors that if
you watch them in other shows they're
always playing a criminal or they're
playing like these kind of sideline
characters background person so for them
to be the leads of this film these are
wonderful things
but it's kind of cheesy I mean part part
of the bun
I thought you said it was hot I
[Laughter]
quickly from Eva Longoria herself about
why this was a project that was so
important to her I read it I was blown
away by Richard montanez's um life and I
was like how do I not know this story
he's Mexican-American he's from my
community I'm Mexican-American everybody
needs to know this story so then I
started getting worried of like oh my
God
why don't we know this story we should
we everybody should know it uh and then
I became obsessed with like I'm the only
person who can tell the story and I went
in and fought for the job and look we
thought at this stage Ted lasso of all
shows was completely over we watched the
finale just a couple of weeks ago but
now Claire Gregory your favorite show
the rumors are they true it's Ted lasso
coming is it back is it back quick quick
have you no longer my favorite show
first series
second seriousness okay I'll still go
with it third sir is not good for me
messy bit of a mess but I will say the
final episode of the third series was
one of my favorite
um uh but now it seems it could be
coming back there was a little tease
from Apple TV plus earlier this week
they posted a photo of the uh the
coaches of uh Richmond saying oh smells
like potential so was that a hint there
could be a spin-off it is for fans
though isn't this hugely frustrating
that it's only just ended come on
shouldn't this be a year down the line
and they tease it you can't just say no
that was the big finale and now it was
actually coming back but perhaps we here
at Sky News we maybe we already knew
that here on Backstage because when we
caught up with Brendan hunt who
co-created the show and writes it yeah
he said three Arc series but he also
said maybe more as for does anything
warrant a spin-off uh yeah I think
there's 20 spin-offs uh that we could do
um uh but maybe we won't do any of them
I don't know and exclusives like that
the very reason that you need to be
listening to the backstage podcast and
if you want to know where to find it
just scan the QR code which is coming up
on your screens at the moment or just go
to wherever you usually find your
podcasts and search for backstage that's
all from us we'll see you next week bye
bye bye